One of the great intellectual puzzles that
daily life forces all of us to consider on
a slightly too regular basis is: ‘Why are
other people so awful? How come they are so
unreliable, aggressive, deceitful, mean, two-faced
or cowardly?’ As we search for answers,
we tend quite naturally to fall back on a
standard, compact and tempting explanation:
because they are terrible people. They are
appalling, crooked, deformed or ‘bad’;
that’s simply how some types are. The conclusion
may be grim, but it also feels very true and
fundamentally unbudgeable. However, when things
feel especially clear cut, we may be goaded
to try out an unusual thought experiment,
which stands to challenge a great many of
our certainties and render the world usefully
more complicated: we can try to look at our
fellow humans through the eyes of love. The
experiment requires particular stamina and
is best attempted at quieter, less agitated
times of day. When we manage it, it may count
as one of our highest ethical achievements.
We are normally resolutely on our side, deeply
invested in our own point of view and prone
to trade in settled and moralising certainties.
Yet, very occasionally, we have the strength
to look at other people through a different
lens: we notice that their reality is likely
to be far more complicated and nuanced than
we first expected – and that, contrary to
our impulses, they may be deserving of more
sympathy and consideration than we thought,
even though they have hurt and frustrated
us, even though their behaviour runs contrary
to what we expect – and even though the
temptation is to call them idiots and numbskulls
and move on.
Looking at another person through the eyes
of love involves some of the following: – Imagination
Moralistic-thinking identifies people closely
with their worst moments. Love-thinking pushes
us in another direction, it bids us to use
our imaginations to picture why someone might
have done a regrettable deed and yet could
remain a fitting target for a degree of understanding
and sympathy. Perhaps they got very frightened,
maybe they were under pressure of extreme
anxiety and despair.
Those who look
with love guess that there will be sorrow
and regret beneath the furious rantings or
a sense of intolerable vulnerability behind
the pomposity and snobbishness. They intimate
that early trauma and let-down must have formed
the backdrop to later transgressions. They
will remember that the person before them
was once a baby too. The loving interpreter
holds on to the idea that sweetness must remain
beneath the surface – along with the possibility
of remorse and growth. They are committed
to mitigating circumstances; to any bits of
the truth that could cast a less catastrophic
light on folly and ‘nastiness’.
To consider others with love means forever remembering the child within them.
Our wrong do'er may be fully grown but their actions will always be connected up with their early years.
We overlook the need occasionally to ignore the outward
adult sides of others in order to perceive
and sympathise with the angry confused infant
lurking inside. When we are around small children
who frustrate us, we don’t don’t declare
them evil, we don’t bear down on them to
show them how misguided they are. We find
less alarming ways of grasping how they have
come to say or do certain things. We don’t
readily assign a negative motive or mean intention
to a small person; we reach around for the
most benevolent interpretations. We probably
think that they are getting a bit tired, or
their gums are sore or they are upset by the
arrival of a younger sibling. We’ve got
a large repertoire of alternative explanations
ready in our heads. This is the reverse of
what tends to happen around adults; here we
imagine that others have deliberately got
us in their sights. But if we employed the
infant model of interpretation, our first
assumption would be quite different. Given
how immature every adult necessarily remains,
some of the moves we execute with relative
ease around children must forever continue
to be relevant when we’re dealing with another
grown-up.
Moralistic thinkers reach their certainties
swiftly; love thinkers take their time. They
remain serene in the face of obviously unimpressive
behaviour: a sudden loss of temper, a wild
accusation, a very mean remark. They reach
instinctively for reasonable explanations
and have clearly in their minds the better
moments of a currently frantic but essentially
loveable person.
Love-thinkers interpret everyone as having strengths alongside
their obvious weaknesses. When they encounter
these weaknesses, they do not conclude that
this is all there is, they know that almost
everything on the negative side of a ledger
could be connected up with something on the
positive. They search a little more assiduously
than is normal for the strength to which a
maddening characteristic must be twinned.
We can see easily enough that someone is pedantic
and uncompromising; we tend to forget, at
moments of crisis, their thoroughness and
honesty. We may know so much about a person’s
messiness, we forget their uncommon degree
of creative enthusiasm. There is no such thing
as a person with only strengths, but nor is
there someone with only weaknesses. The consolation
comes in refusing to view defects in isolation.
Love is built out of a constantly renewed
and gently resigned awareness that weakness-free
people do not exist. – We Are Sinners Too
The single greatest spur towards a loving
perspective on others is a live awareness
that we are also deeply imperfect and at points
quite plainly mad. The enemy of generosity
is the sense that we might be beyond fault
– whereas love begins when we can acknowledge
that we are in equal measures idiotic, mentally
wobbly and flawed. It’s an implicit faith
in their own perfection that turns some people
into such harsh judges Looking at the world
through the eyes of love, we are forced to
conclude that there is no such thing as a
simply bad person, and no such thing as a
monster. There is only ever pain, anxiety
and suffering that have coalesced into unfortunate
action. We are not just being kind in this
notion; this isn’t merely an exercise in
being nice, it’s an exercise in getting
to the truth of things, which may – when
we get down to the details of human psychology
– be roughly and almost coincidentally the
same thing.
To learn more about love and how to find love, which explains why we have the types we do and how our earlier experiences shape how and whom we love.